mes chers collègues nous poursuivons nos
travaux et l'audition de monsieur
olivier ferrand ministre des solidarités
et de la santé que nous remercions pour
sa présence dans un contexte épidémique
que nous avons toujours tendu bienvenue
monsieur le ministre
l'intervention des cabinets de conseil
dans le secteur sanitaire n'est pas
nouvelle elle a toutefois pu susciter
une certaine émotion dans l'opinion
publique lors de la crise sanitaire et
cabinet roland berger guerre situer les
j2l sont intervenus dans l'organisation
logistique de distribution des masques
puis des tests mckinsey a travaillé sur
la campagne vaccinale accenture est
intervenu sur plusieurs systèmes
d'information comme le sii vaccin ou le
pass sanitaire de même que cgi france le
montant de ces prestations s'élevait à
près de 25 millions d'euros en septembre
2021 cette audition devant nous
permettre d'obtenir des chiffres
actualisés le groupe communiste a
demandé cette commission d' enquête pour
mieux comprendre les mécanismes
d'intervention des cabinets de conseil
dans les politiques publiques en général
et la clé sanitaires en particulier
dames la rapporteure l'a répété à
plusieurs reprises nous ne sommes ni des
juges du des procureurs ne sommes pas là
pour faire des procès d'intention mais
pour investiguer sur des faits tous les
faits rien que les faits eux mêmes ne
sommes pas là pour minimiser l'ampleur
de la crise sanitaire ni le travail
accompli par l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires pour y faire face dans
les hôpitaux bien sûr mais aussi dans
l'administration centrale et
déconcentrée
si notre pays est tenu bon c'est grâce à
nos agents publics le 9 février 2021
vous avez déclaré devant l'assemblée
nationale
on a du talent dans le privé et dans le
public aussi nous ne pouvons que
souscrire à ces propos sous réserve que
l'administration ne devienne pas
dépendante de ceux ci étaient privés en
particulier dans le secteur sanitaire et
dans les domaines régaliens
nos questions sont en réalité très
simple pourquoi avoir eu recours à des
cabinets de conseil comme ont ils été
recruté pour quelles missions comment
ont-ils été évalué faut dire que
l'audition de santé publique france n'a
pas permis de répondre à ces questions
pourtant essentielles
nous merci on avance monsieur le
ministre pour vous répondre sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets factuel service
où ils ont d'ores et déjà transmis des
pièces nous en parlons transmis les
pièces
nombreuses très nombreuses même dans un
esprit coopératif que ne pouvons que
souligner je précise que cette audition
est ouverte au public et à la presse
elle est retransmise en direct sur le
site internet du sénat et en raison du
contexte sanitaire nos collègues peuvent
également intervenir par visioconférence
comme pour toutes les personnes
auditionnées je rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant une autre commission
denquête est passible de sanctions
pénales qui peuvent aller selon les
circonstances de droit à sept ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 cent mille
euros damende vous invite donc monsieur
le ministre a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je le jure je le
jure merci monsieur le ministre vous
laisse maintenant la parole pour une
intervention liminaire environ 10
minutes si vous voulez bien pour que
nous ayons ensuite le temps d'échangés à
travers les questions mais hamelin
rapporteur et de nos collègues vous avez
la parole monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président madame la rapporteure
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un exercice de transparence que je
suis appelé aujourd'hui je me soumets
bien volontiers ce n'est pas le premier
d'ailleurs je le fais depuis le premier
jour d'une crise sanitaire qui a
toujours donné toute sa place à la
mission de contrôle du parlement c'est
bien normal et ce n'est pas l'ancien
parlementaire que je suis qui vous dira
le contraire
le sujet du recours au cabinet de
conseil c'est à mon sujet si je puis me
permettre il mérite effectivement de la
clarté ils méritent également de la
hauteur je sais que nous ne manquerons
pas il n'y a pas d'un côté l'état et de
l'autre de sombres prédateurs privé qui
s'enrichirait à ses dépens vous le savez
les politiques publiques de solidarité
de santé sont aujourd'hui confrontés à
un environnement qui est en profonde
évolution est en constante évolution
évolution des risques qui pèsent sur nos
concitoyens évolution des prises en
charge rendue possible par les progrès
de la médecine plus globalement de nos
connaissances et expériences l'évolution
des attentes de nos concitoyens
également révolution numérique etc ces
évolutions et nécessitent d'adapter sans
cesse les réponses que nous apportons et
l'organisation des ressources pour les
mettre en oeuvre sur une période récente
on pourrait citer la création de la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
la stratégie de transformation du
système de santé l'objectif de faire de
l'exercice coordonnées en santé la norme
pour la prise en charge des patients et
ainsi faire reculer les déserts médicaux
c'est dans ce contexte de transformation
que doit être replacé le recours à des
cabinets de conseil par l'administration
et dont le cadre d'utilisation ses
structures et ses dernières années
le secrétaire général de mon ministère
etienne champions le délégué
interministériel à la transformation
public thierry lambert que vous avez
tous deux entendus précédemment ont
détaillé chacun pour ce qui le concerne
au sein de mon ministère ou dans
d'autres directions dont la direction
interministérielle pour la
transformation public le rôle des
différents acteurs pour encadrer et
contrôler le recours à ces prestations
de conseil l'objectif nous assurer
qu'elle soit utilisée conformément au
cadre réglementaire mais également à bon
escient c'est à dire pour renforcer la
capacité d'action de l'état à un moment
donné sur un sujet qui nécessite une
expertise particulière et ce en appui
aux agents publics les cabinets de
conseil constitue donc une ressource
utile pour démultiplier l'action des
agents dans un certain nombre de cas
pour faire face aux besoins en
compétences expertes à un moment donné
pour faire face à un projet limité dans
le temps que les équipes ne peuvent pas
intégrer complètement pour disposer d'un
regard extérieur affûté sur des
situations comparables dans d'autres
environnements d'autres ministères
d'autres pays des entreprises etc
notamment pour proposer des évolutions
des organisations dans le champ
spécifique du numérique des
externalisations ont été engagés sur des
fonctions opérationnelles
si les domaines à plus forte valeur
ajoutée comme le pilotage et la
conception doivent être durablement
porter en interne le recrutement de
développeurs revêtent une importance
croissante ainsi que celui d'experts de
la donner j'étais avant de vous
rejoindre sur un forum européen dans le
cas de la présidence française de
l'union européenne consacré par exemple
à l'évolution des règles éthiques en
matière de stockage et d'utilisation des
données de santé nous dit on discute on
a 27 et les 27 qui composent l'union
européenne font appel à des compétences
internes mais aussi externes sur des
sujets aussi pointus que celui ci en
complément c'est indispensable
savoir-faire interne il est donc
nécessaire de recourir
à des expertises externes pour la
conception le design le développement la
diffusion de produits numériques j'y
reviendrai dans ce cas particulier de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire en
revanche le positionnement du cabinet de
conseil est très claire il vient
toujours en appui ou conseil d'un chef
de projet interne à l'administration
dans le cadre d'une expression de
besoins clairement définis et avec des
livrables clairement identifié la
restitution de ces travaux se fait
également dans un cadre défini en amont
de la commande le commanditaire est
clairement identifiés ainsi que le
dispositif de pilotage de la prestation
l'objectif est que l'appréciation de
conseil nous permettent pleinement
d'éclairer le décideur public mais que
les choses soient claires jamais jamais
no6 substitut on trouve par exemple
cette frontière inscrite noir sur blanc
dans les documents contractuels qui nous
lie avec le cabinet mckinsey que vous
avez cités tout à l'heure les devis
exclut toute forme de conseil en
politiques publiques en droit en matière
médicale et bien entendu de substitution
en matière décisionnel ces cabinets de
conseils viennent par ailleurs toujours
en complément des ressources internes
que ce soit les ressources des
directions du ministère ou celle de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales le recours aux cabines conseil
a connu une actualité particulière
pendant la crise sanitaire oui
personne n'ignore que l'ampleur de la
crise sanitaire que nous traversons est
sans précédent et mon ministère possède
un dispositif efficace de prévention et
de réponse aux crises sanitaires mais
l'ampleur la crise a nécessité de
mobiliser dans un temps record des raves
des renforts importants en nombre et en
expertise je vous donner le détail de
ces renforts pour que vous puissiez
aussi comparer
parce que ces renforts sont venus de
différentes sources
d'abord de capacités internes du
ministère via l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales notamment à la date du
1er juin 2021 112 mission d'appui crise
avait été assurée dans le cadre de la
crise qu'ovide via l'igas dont 84 en
administration centrale et 28 au sein
des agences régionales de santé
ensuite ils proviennent de serre
chaussée ces renforts viennent
proviennent aussi de contrats
spécifiques de renforts et la 226
contrat pour 2021 132 contrats
inférieurs à 6 mois 83 contrat de 6 à 12
mois on ce contrat de 12 mois et enfin
de capacités externe interministériel le
ministère a reçu des enfants de
l'inspection générale des finances de la
déité du ministère des armées du
ministère de l'intérieur notamment à
côté cela des cabinets privés sont
intervenus recherchés pour leur
expertise spécifique logistique systèmes
d'information notamment et pour leur
capacité à mobiliser très rapidement des
équipes importantes et experte on peut
retenir que les permanents additionné
aux renforts ont constitué une base de
450 500 agents dont une centaine
d'intervenants externe et je tiens aussi
à souligner que ces renforts qu'il
provient de l'igas d'autres ministères
de contrats spécifiques ou de
prestataires privés se sont ajoutés à
une mobilisation absolument exceptionnel
de mon administration dgs dg os dgcs
bien sûr au premier plan mais aussi
l'adresse qui publie toutes ces données
la dss la dicom la direction des
affaires juridiques que je ne
remercierai jamais assez croyez moi pour
le travail monumental qu'ils effectuent
monumental jour et nuit elle semaine et
week-end pour le reste mon secrétaire
général vous a adressé 50 gigaoctets de
données numériques qui représentent
plusieurs milliers de pages de documents
vous permettant en toute transparence
d'aller piocher ce qui vous semble utile
ou important dans le cadre de votre
commission tous les agents du ministère
sur leurs fonctions propres ou en
redéploiement se sont engagés dans la
gestion de crise qui s'est ajoutée à
leur mission permanente je pourrais vous
livrer des témoignages un directeur de
rs me disais que jusqu'ici quelqu'un qui
était en charge de l'inspection des eaux
dont c'était le métier comme ingénieur
s'est retrouvé à faire des tableaux
excel de répartition des doses fader
pendant les premières semaines de la
campagne vaccinale pour s'assurer que
chaque centre étaient achalandés au
prorata du nombre de rendez vous qui
avait été pris et je ne parle pas
évidemment de l'extension horaire du
travail de nombreux agents publics je
tiens à dire ici à saluer parce que sans
eux nous n'y serions pas arrivés
évidemment pour autant en comparant les
moyens consacrés aux prestations de
conseil dans le contexte de la crise au
moyen qui leur était consacrée en 2019
par exemple on constate que ces camps
sans commune mesure on recense ainsi 54
commandes entre mars 2020 et aujourd'hui
pour un montant global de 26 79 millions
d'euros à rapprocher du montant global
de 1 717 millions engagés en 2019 sur un
périmètre équivalent le coût de ces
prestations reste toutefois modérée au
regard de l'ensemble des dépenses liées
à la crise sanitaire je le rappelle 30
milliards d'euros entre 2020 et 2021
dont 7 milliards d'euros pour l'hôpital
nous avons très récemment tout début
2022 à nouveau contractualiser avec le
cabinet mckinsey en renfort de la
campagne de vaccination pédiatriques
cette fois et ce jusqu'à la date du 4
février 2022 c'est à dire après demain
je ne veux pas plus quant au contenu des
prestations demandées au cabinet de
conseil elle recouvre principalement
trois grands chambre la programmation la
logistique et les systèmes d'information
de crise initié afin de disposer
d'outils numériques apte à gérer une
pandémie en portant la totalité de la
population française je jure je le redis
trois semaines je crois qu'il a fallu
pour développer sa dette
quand on a parlé initialement d'un
système d'information commun à tous les
laboratoires avec une centralisation des
données mais de sécurisation des données
permettant d'avoir un regard exhaustif
et de montée du contact du contact
racing si on m'avait dit avant ça
prendrait trois semaines si on vous
l'avez dit vous auriez dit c'est
impossible or ça a été fait vac si le
système d'information pour la
vaccination pareil le bastani terre et
ses multiples révisions pareil vous en
trouverez donc le détail dans les
documents transmis par le secrétaire
général du ministère mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la période
exceptionnelle de crise sanitaire que
nous traversons devra nous permettre de
nous améliorer pour l'avenir comme nous
avons déjà eu à coeur de nous améliorer
au fur et à mesure des différentes
vagues pour assurer la réponse la plus
réactive la plus efficace possible à nos
concitoyens dans le respect du cadre
démocratique et administratifs nous
pouvons déjà toutefois souligné que les
agents du ministère ont fait preuve d'un
engagement et d'une adaptabilité
remarquable c'est toute une
administration qui s'est mobilisé
ils se mobilisent encore pour répondre à
la crise dont environ 400 à 500 agents
directement dans les cellules de crise
en administration centrale au plus près
de la pandémie sans compter bien entendu
des équipes des ars 7 jours sur 7 h 24
qui combattent l'épidémie tout cela
depuis maintenant deux ans sans
interruption je crois qu'il faut saluer
la mobilisation exceptionnelle de
l'ensemble des agents publics qui ont
constitué le premier rempart face à la
crise et que des cabinets de conseils de
consultants ne viendront jamais
remplacer même si leur expertise comme
leur capacité à mobiliser très
rapidement et sur une période illimitée
des équipes ciblées sur les besoins
urgents aura constitué un appui je le
dis indispensable sans lequel notre
réponse n'aurait pas pu être ce qu'elle
a été nous étions astreints à une
obligation de résultat protéger la santé
des français face à face à cette
épidémie sans précédent nous avons
mobilisé toutes les ressources
disponibles dans ce seul objectif et
avant de conclure je vous dirais que si
vous aviez une image à visualiser c'est
celle de la bibliothèque simone veil
cette magnifique bibliothèque art déco
du ministère des solidarités et la santé
qui a été transformé en immense open
space ouverte le dimanche et les nuits
ou des tableaux de bords ont fait leur
apparition au milieu des rayonnages des
ouvrages et des livres et où les
personnes se sont succédées issus de
tous les corps de métier d ingénieur des
logisticiens des militaires des civils
du public du privé certains d'ailleurs
étant venu dans l'urgence dire j'ai des
compétences à vous apporter et qu'ils en
soient remerciés
merci monsieur le ministre pour ses
propos liminaires mesdames le rapporteur
va poser les premières questions
bonjour monsieur le ministre
je reviens pas sur les propos du
président bazin qu'il a prononcé en
ouverture de cette audition et sur les
propos qui ont terminé votre votre
intervention liminaire bien évidemment
nous saluons et nous sommes fiers de
l'engagement de celles et ceux qui ont
dû faire face dans des conditions
difficiles
qui ont dû faire face à cette épidémie
qui n'est malheureusement pas même si
les choses se sont améliorées qui me qui
n'est pas encore tout à fait terminée
je
j'ai une question à vous poser dans un
premier temps c'est précisément sur le
rôle des cabinets de conseil dans la
prise de décision mais je voudrais quand
même insisté sur le fait que notre
vocation la vocation de cette commission
denquête c'est vraiment de comprendre de
comprendre pourquoi ces derniers temps
il y a eu un recours en augmentation des
cabinets de conseil privé sur des
missions qui nous semble quand même
importante et nous voulons comprendre
parce que
comprendre ça a peut supposer que un
certain nombre de d'éléments qui nous
paraissent opaque puisse être levé et
gagner surtout en transparence
à la demande de la commission d' enquête
le ministère a transmis dont vous l'avez
dit l'ensemble des livrables des
cabinets de conseils pendant la crise
sanitaire et sincèrement nous vous en
remercions
toutefois leur lecture donne quand même
le vertige
car elle les montre une intervention
massive de ces cabinets sur tous les
pans de la crise sanitaire et sur des
missions qui nous semblait relever de
l'administration est donc là nous avons
l'exemple d'un livrables de matrix est
en date du 23 août 2000 21 qui fait un
bilan des injections vaccinales réalisés
à cette date qui établit des projections
sur la vaccination pour atteindre la
cime de 50 millions de primo vaccination
que le gouvernement s'était fixé en
septembre
2021 de ma première question est simple
c'est quel a été le rôle de mckinsey
dans l'établissement de ses projections
vaccinale par exemple en septembre 2021
est dans la même logique deuxième
question ce document de mckinsey a été
transmis au conseil de défense sanitaire
le 23 août 2021 et cette information
figure d'ailleurs voix ressemblant aux
jeunes européens noir sur fond jaune
sur le document donc ces documents de
mckinsey ont-ils outil est qu'il était
utilisé par le conseil de défense pour
préparer ces décisions sinon pourquoi
les transmettre et vous pouvez
comprendre là encore monsieur le
ministre que cette question est
importante car le conseil de défense à
interroger et interroge encore sur son
périmètre et sur ses missions je vous
remercie pour vos réponses
je vous réponds volontiers s'agit pas
d'un livrables documents que vous
montrez on en a beaucoup avait
effectivement des comme celui-ci
renouveler très régulièrement j'avais
un tableau de bord j'ai toujours un
tableau de bord sur lequel sont aimantés
des documents qui permet de rendre
compte de façon très visuelle est très
rapide de la progression la campagne
vaccinale de l'utilisation des
consommables des perspectives
d'utilisation du consommable des
commandes éventuels qui compile les
sondages et enquêtes d'opinion pour
savoir jusqu'où on peut monter dans la
vaccination quels sont les leviers keita
ou que moi j'ai besoin d'avoir ce visuel
qui permet d'avoir
la crise est très vaste en terme
d'action et de de connaissances à
acquérir et et actualisée au quotidien
ce ne sont pas des livrables pardonnez
moi ce sont des documents internes au
ministère qui relève des équipes du
ministère et auquel mckinsey a participé
donc ce ne sont pas des documents
estampillés mckinsey que le cabinet de
conseil nous livrerait tel quel
maintenant ce sont des documents qui
sont ils sont dans les équipes et donc
ce sont des documents des équipes du
ministère qui sont
estampillés ministère des solidarités de
la santé
tu du renfort d'équipés il se substitue
pas et vous avez parlé de la prise de
décision à aucun moment mckinsey ne m'a
fait prendre une décision en lien avec
la crise sanitaire et où l'accueil la
campagne vaccinale chez ministre si ce
document n'est pas un livrable nous dit
donc un document interne au ministère
sur lequel était intervenu maquis ne
sais si j'ai bien compris c'est quand
même un document qui a été transmis au
conseil de défense pourquoi tu es un
document du ministère de la santé
produit par les équipes du ministère de
la santé qui sont derrière un document
que si nous permettons de vous les livre
et vous vous permettez de les montrer
qu'ils ne sont pas des documents qui
sont classés une classifiés et qui porte
sur des données transparentes public
nous rendrons public très régime
sioniste vous nous permettrez nous aussi
nous interroger sur l'intervention de
mckinsey sur c'est beaucoup même si je
le répète vous nous dites que c'est un
document interne au ministère de
l'intérieur
le sens de votre question jour de leurs
formules et parce que comme on est en
commission denquête j'ai besoin de
vraiment comprendre ce qu'on nous avait
dit que ces documents que se remontre
est un document qui a été réalisé par
les services du ministère oui mais
vraiment
ma question est simple est-ce que ma
kiné est intervenu sur l'élaboration de
ce document mckinsey faisait à renforcer
l'ensemble des équipes en charge de la
politique vaccinale est donc ce n'est
pas un document mckinsey êtes un an
j'ai bien précisé je me sécher un
document du ministère
je vous réponds que mckinsey a contribué
à ces documents donc il est intervenu
mais ils sont cons ils sont assis sans
aucun problème avec ça si l'on
apprécié d un petit peu les choses ce
qu'on a fait on est au commission
denquête il faut que les définitions se
précise on entend bien
la société mckinsey a participé à
l'élaboration du document mais dans quel
cadre à ce moment là parce que
normalement quand on passe une un
contrat avec une société de conseil on
lui confie une mission quelle qu'elle
remplit de façon satisfaisante ou pas
c'est l'administration qui apprécie mais
vous nous dites là que ces gens là
étaient en renfort donc c'était est-ce
que c'était simplement une prestation de
complément ou est ce qu'il y avait une
commande précise un mac kinsey
d'abord là on parle d'une situation qui
est absolument exceptionnelle on est
d'accord on parle pas d'une situation du
quotidien situation exceptionnelle où
chaque jour et même parfois même
plusieurs fois par jour on a eu besoin
de faire le point sur combien de
seringue et sont disponibles dans tel
centre combien de dispositifs nous
disent nous avons encore en stock dans
les locaux de santé publique france
combien de vaccination ont été réalisés
sur la journée d'hier avec des
répartition régionale est ce qu'on voit
des disparités et c'est qu'on brasse une
foule de données qui sont d'ailleurs des
données qu qui pour la plupart sont
rendus accessibles en open data et
documents que vous montrez sont des
documents qui rendent compte de façon
visuelle de tout ou partie des
indicateurs dont nous disposons ces
documents sont réalisés par les équipes
du ministère et nous avons eu besoin
dans cette période de campagne vaccinale
de renforcer les effectifs de nos
équipes par des prestataires issus de ce
cabinet de conseil qui sont venus avec
leurs propres compétences pour renforcer
les équipes donc on n'est pas dans un
pour ça que je fais vraiment la
distinction nous n'avons pas demandé au
cabinet privé mckinsey devient d'avoir
la gentillesse de réaliser des documents
fournis à lyon conseil de défense nous
avons demandé du renfort rh des équipes
de mckinsey pour venir en appui de nos
propres équipes internes participé à la
mise en exergue de tous ces enjeux
logistique c'est vraiment de cela dont
il s'étend il s'est agi ce sont des
tourments logistiques donc lieu c est ce
qu'on va trouver dans les documents qui
nous sont transmis la commande précise
pour ceux la situation que vous évoquez
instant mais ce sont des commandes qui
sont internes et donc nous avons des
ressources humaines que nous avons
intégré à nos équipes pour une durée
donnée pour des missions données dans le
cadre de la campagne vaccinale
et quand je vous dis que nous avons eu
des renforts externe qui venait parfois
d'ailleurs lorsque tu voulais quand on a
fait venir des généraux tient aux jo et
mondiaux parler d'eux j'étais allé une
fois sorties publiques france pour le
cellule vaccinale non cellule masque
c'est vrai c'est l'une des masques j'ai
parlé avec des officiers de gendarmerie
qui était en tenue et qu'ils étaient à
santé publique france ce sont des gens
qui sont venus avec leurs compétences et
qui sont venus renforcer nos effectifs
parce que nous avons nous avions besoin
de compétences logistiques pour pouvoir
nous appuyer sur des missions précises
je vous rappelle l'urgence éminente
qu'il y avait à fournir des masques au
maximum dans les territoires elle est
déclinée est allé chercher en chine etc
vous aviez la des compétences dans un
non pas un melting-pot parce que vous
allez mal prendre le leterme s'était pas
le s'était pas tout était très structuré
et organisé mais nous avions dont des
renforts de compétences précises dont
nous avions besoin certaines venaient du
secteur public du secteur privé
certaines de cabinet de conseil en
renfort dans le cas de la campagne
vaccinale sont les équipes de mckinsey
qui sont venus en renfort compléter les
équipes internes au ministère
jeu j'espère avoir répondu à votre
question dans ce que ma question par été
totalement factuel et ce qu'on a dans
les pièces qui nous sont transmises
la commande qui correspond à cette
prestation
des contrats si les contrats nous sont
transmis on les examinera pour
comprendre mieux mais je
je voudrais revenir sur la question de
la décision évidemment vous ne doit-on
non pas à une autre réponse de la part
d'un responsable public qui prend
l'appui d'un cabinet de conseil pour
répondre à une situation que de
revendiquer la décision qui en décolle
et tous vos collègues qui sont passés
avant vous on en fait de même cela va de
soi maintenant c'est tout ce que la
situation les situations sont beaucoup
plus compliquées que que cette
présentation un peu binaire des choses
parce que les éléments qu'on vous
transmets
contiennent déjà des éléments
d'orientation plus ou moins subtiles
nous avons par exemple dans les haies
les éléments que vous avez transmis hier
à relever une note du 27 octobre 2020
prégnant préparé par le cabinet roland
berger heures et qui porte sur la dispo
distribution de gants médicaux du stock
stratégique de la france ya trois
scénarios qui seront proposés je passe
les détails je vais directement la
conclusion de la note les options 2 et 3
ne permettent pas d'envisager une
reconstitution du stock stratégique
avant 2021 font perdurer un système où
les acteurs bénéficie d'une distribution
de sécurité de l'état sans que celle ci
soit de nature à les inciter à l'arrêté
de s'approvisionner par eux mêmes
votre arbitrage est sollicité sur le
choix de l'option à privilégier
mais ce qu'il ya vraiment un arbitrage
politique à faire quand on a une telle
démonstration
préalable le consultant ferme les portes
la porte à deux des trois scénarios donc
il vous reste simplement à bénir le
troisième
que je me fasse bien comprendre que le
consultant proposent ce type de
raisonnement peut le suivre mais il me
semble qu'il ya une couche interposés
quand même avant la décision publique et
celle de votre administration
qui doit re digérer ces éléments tandis
que là il voue son pipe sont que ces
éléments vous a été présentée
directement ni trouvé le conflit pas du
tout
tout passe par le filtre de la direction
générale de la santé lorsque sa
direction générale de la santé donc le
nom a aucune transmission directe j'ai
jamais eu à vous connaître d'une note
transmise directement d'un cabinet de
conseil jusqu'à mon bureau en vue de
valider une option ou une autre nom et
par ailleurs je me permets de vous dire
que si je m'étais arrêté et là je ne
parle pas de cabinet de conseil mais par
définition de ma propre administration
si j'avais fait à chaque fois le choix
enfin je n'ai je n'ai pas fait à chaque
fois le choix kim était guidé par une
administration encore une fois pas un
cabinet de conseil une administration il
m'est arrivé de faire des choix qui
était différent que les options qui
était présenté comme une option qu'il
fallait retenir c'est d'ailleurs le
propre du politique que d'être capable
de prendre des arbitrages qui
contreviennent parfois à l'esprit
général du corps administratif non pas
pour les embêter ou non pas pour des
raisons obscures mais parce qu'on
considère que l'acceptabilité de telle
ou telle décision dépeint n'est pas
aussi d'être que cela tous d'accord sur
ce point là monsieur ministre ma
question et vous y avez répondu je
répondu j'ai pas de nox cabinet de
conseil son bureau avec la mer viennent
pas directement elles sont
systématiquement retraite non seulement
ils sont retraités par l'administration
mais ensuite elles sont retraités par
mon cabinet et ensuite à mon directeur
de cabinet et quand une note il revient
sur mon bureau pour arbitrage elle a
déjà été avisés en général vous savez
j'ai un parent a juré que vous apportez
vous avez un parent avec la colonne et
les de plusieurs colonnes c'est
l'expérience de ces systèmes voilà celle
des dates de signature je le dis pour
les français qui nous regardent des
dates de signature par tel ou tel membre
du cabinet il ya la liste des 3 4 5 6
personnes vous avez dans la première
liste ensuite vous ouvrez vous avez
d'abord la lettre qui vous est adressée
par directeurs d'administrations qui
explique pourquoi lui propose un
arbitrage puis vous avez la note de
votre cabinet qui vous guide pour vous
pour vous permettre de faire le juste
choix et enfin vous avez un document que
vous pouvez signer ou sur la page de
couverture du paraphe vous mettez vue et
c est cet envoyé voilà comme ça regardez
vous montrer des trucs je montre aussi
ça c'est par exemple le dossier en vue
de l'audition physiquement bien qu'elle
a été préparée été préparé donc elle a
été visée en date du 2 par mon directeur
de cabinet en date du 1er par ma
conseillère spéciale à visée par le
directeur de cabinet adjoint
et elle a été avisé par mon conseiller
parlementaire qui est ici présents hier
même plus une petit à petit mot c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne donc je n'ai
jamais dansé par à plat regardez la
joindre aux notes et d'un cabinet de
conseil passer ça n'existe pas
même le rapporteur
monsieur minimes et encore vous poser un
question sur un deuxième exemple oui
tout ça c'est sur la base des documents
que nous avons reçus et nous n'avons
rien inventé
on à la fois satisfaire votre demande et
la fois on a bien conscience que vous
envoyez des milliers de pages de
documents c'est c'est aussi l'assurance
de pouvoir se noyer donc je vous serais
très heureux pour exercer sa sortie en
sortie donc
là allez on est un petit peu en arrière
on né le 8 juillet 2021 d'accord soit
quatre jours avant l'intervention du
président de la république donc le 12
juillet pour annoncer donc la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants et
l'extension du pass sanitaire au lieu de
loisirs et de culture met d'accord
jusqu'à donc ma qui disait encore lui
rédige une guerre que c'est peut-être
parce à un livrable intitulé qui hélas
sécurisé l'objectif de 40 millions de
vaccinés
afin d' accord
tout de suite quel est le logo qui est
sûre documents
jetés marché mckinsey quelque part dans
paris match il est marqué quel logo
ministère donc non c'était pas un
livrable de mckinsey zombies un terme à
ce qu'on appelle le cabinet colline où
la task force vaccinale qui relève
directement mon autorité au sein du
ministère d'accord je veux qu'on soit
très précis alors messieurs vous dans
ces cas là on va être très précis et je
vais lèvres
il y à une note je sais pas si je vais
la retrouver voilà mes notes halak qui a
été rédigé à l'administration
à l'attention de monsieur le directeur
général de la santé objet planification
de la dissolution de la cellule de
coordination interministérielle
logistique les moyens sanitaires
ccms
cette note a été rédigée par deux
personnes
le dossier était suivi par deux
personnes dont une
qui est salariée d'un cabinet privé
et
une haute direction d'une note la
direction générale de la santé peut être
réalisée par des études qui viennent en
renfort et son cabinet privé oui kes de
ken et allemands je m'étais de récession
subie ce n'est pas dérangeant notre sens
que document estampillé ministère des
solidarités j'avais pas finie y aller et
c'est
manifestement
la personne qui rédige cela n'est pas
aussi âge de mckinsey pts la personne
qui a dit cela c'est le principe
pardonnez-moi du dre de renfort du
conseil c'est une personne qui est
délégué par le cabinet en raison de ses
compétences au sein d'une équipe au sein
du ministère
je crois que c'est la règle en principe
de conseil lorsque vous faites appel à
des ressources
extérieur à vos ressources humaines
internes par définition les personnes
vous les intégrer le temps de leur
mission à votre équipe oui mais quand on
est en train d'accord on est d'accord
sauf que vous nous dites quand je vais
vous poser ma deuxième question que ce
n'est pas un document mike et mckinsey
puisqu'il est estampillé ministère de la
cdc l'hilarité de la santé d'accord j'ai
eu un temps mais on fera des recherches
que vous avez demandé nous andré vous
envoyer la totalité des documents
auxquels le cabinet a plus contribué de
près ou de loin d'où l'exhaustivité des
pièces que nous avons livré de manière
que nous soyons aux visions fassions
faits reprochés le fait d'avoir renoncé
à dire que tout document auquel mckinsey
a contribué de près ou de loin on nous
avait envoyé si vous devez si vous aviez
demandé la liste des documents
estampillés mckinsey présents dans le
dossier où vous auriez une feuille
blanche la sénatrice vous avez là tous
les documents auxquels ils ont pu
contribuer ils ont pu
contribué de près ou de loin ainsi que
des renforts rh interne internaliser
dans nos équipes le temps des missions
et sans pouvoir décisionnel et sans lien
direct avec les ministres
n'a parlé que j'ai
juste une précision j'ai district 6 mois
à pratiquer d'administration qui est
aussi un peu longue
plutôt que
la note soit rédigée et clairement avec
un dossier suivi par l'agent qui relève
de votre responsabilité que le renfort
puisse être annexés si vous voulez mais
c'est peut-être cette colline demi
confusion qui peut peut-être perturbé
maints la reporter est ce que vous ne
trouveriez pas plus logique de bien
séparer les deux tout simplement c'est
pas donc j'ai
une idée c'est pas la vérité toute la
vérité c'est votre sentiment c'est
toujours le cas en temps normal ça n'est
jamais ou très rarement le cas en
situation exceptionnelle
deuxième sonne logisticiens ça pose pas
de difficultés dans sept agents d'armes
je vous ai dit un gendarme qui était des
gendarmes et des militaires intégrés à
la cellule vaccinale qui ont participé
au sein des équipes normale du ministère
à la gestion logistique jeu ça ne gêne
personne c'est un gendarme cinq
militaires donc et quand c'est un camp
c'est un ingénieur ou un logisticien
professionnel qui vient du privé il y
aurait une discussion je vous dis que
les règles qui permettent de se
soustraire à cette suspicion sont les
règles très claires aucun pouvoir
décisionnel des contrats passés qui sont
claires une évaluation et dans
l'attribution des marchés me suivi
strictement prévues par la loi donc je
jeu pour ça que j'ai à dire j'avais dit
cette interview je vous remercie de
l'avoir cité en introduction parce que
je la revendique il ya des ressources et
des talents dans le secteur privé et des
ressources et des talents notre secteur
public quand on est en période de crise
exceptionnelle vaudois mènent une
campagne vaccinale tambour battant sauf
à ce que vous considériez qu'on serait
aller trop vite fait je crois pas que
c'était des situations début de la
campagne
vous allez chercher les compétences là
où elles sont et vous pouvez vous
enorgueillir d'avoir un beau pays dans
lequel vous trouver de très belles
compétences diversifiées en public et en
privé là on avait juste besoin d'une
masse de gens beaucoup plus importante
que d'habitude donc on a rempli on a
gonflé les équipes avec des compétences
et des talents qui venaient de
différents secteurs mais encore une fois
les règles sont claires donc je me
permets de mettre un logo gendarmerie
sur un bout de documents parce qu'il ya
un jardin qui a participé à la collecte
des informations confirmées constitué
jetables ou
renoncer en train de l'agent public et
salariés du privé ses choix je vous
parle d'une équipe mais songez aux
statuts différenciés georges évidemment
que ce qui ce qui fait question enfin la
commission je vais essayer de vous
exprimer le mieux possible qui ne fait
pas partie de l'administration comme
jérôme bascher ni de près ni c'est que
quand on fait appel à des cabinets de
conseils habituellement sur la base d'un
contrôleur confie une mission et là vous
nous expliquer que vous avez intégré des
compétences à l'intérieur de vos équipes
et je vais regarder avec mes collègues
de près dans les contrats vous allez
nous faire suivre comment son bordel en
fonction parce que on a l'impression la
queue on appris des agents publics entre
guillemets dans un vivier privé sans
avoir
passé un marché clair sur une mission
précise avec les cabinets privés si
la pardonnez moi ou si vous sortez du
cadre vous êtes en train de conclure ou
de dégoût d'insinuer qu'il y aurait des
marchés qui ne serait pas clair je vous
répondais prouvez le nous avons envoyé
des mois que je sais que je le précise
des choses
une ambiguïté dans la nature des
contractions passé est dans la nature de
et dans le land art réalisation des
contrats qui son père allait rentrer en
parle encore une fois d'une situation
comprenait le et je suis sûr que vous le
comprenez on parle d'une situation
exceptionnelle d'extrême urgence un
présent la république dit notre pays est
en guerre nous avons besoin de
compétences nous avons besoin de talents
nous avons besoin d'aller vite tout le
monde nous demande d'aller vite les
sénateurs comme le reste des citoyens
français et tout le monde a raison de
demander d'aller très vite nous prenons
quand même évidemment la peine de
respecter les codes des marchés publics
les règles en matière de recrutement les
règles d'attribution des marchés nous
passons des contrats et nous vérifions
que les contrats sont parfaitement
limpide et nous respectons tous les
règlements en vigueur en matière de
l'appel à des ressources humaines
extérieur nous internalise on nous
analysons nous renforçons nos équipes
avec les personnes ressources qui
proviennent de l'extérieur du public et
du privé pour faire la guerre pour faire
la guerre il est tout à fait normal que
nous rendions des comptes nous vous
présentons la totalité des contrats des
documents auxquels de près ou de loin
les uns et les autres en plus participer
et je réponds à vos questions et bajaj
insiste sur le fait qu'il y aille je
vous le redis je suis foncièrement il
n'y a aucun moment à aucun moment un
coin de contrat ou une dérogation qui
ont été faites au fonctionnement et aux
règlements en vigueur en revanche ce qui
a changé c'est la pratique c'est à dire
que là où habituellement vous avez une
clarification des missions extérieures
avec des choses qui sont totalement
board est effectivement externalise là
vous avez à l'enrichissement d'une
équipe parce que si vous devez en
période de guerre commencé à regarder
qui et à quel endroit à la personne va
préparer les munitions et l'autre va
vérifier que les munitions sont bien
transféré dans l'arsenal vous avez pas
vous en sortir mais je n'ai absolument
rien insinué monsieur le ministre
simplement je vous interroger sur ce
point votre réponse est extrêmement père
nous n'avons pas encore regardé ces
documents qui nous sont parvenues hier
je vous exprimer notre
questionnement vis-à-vis de ce type de
contrat auquel nous ne sommes absolument
pas habitués jamais vu ça moi j'ai géré
quelques que
nous allons les examiner nous verrons
le ministre nous aussi nous savons qu'il
ya des compétences d'entraidé moi je
viens du privé avant d'être d'avoir
rejoint à la fonction publique
territoriale donc il ya des talents et
des compétences dans le privé que les
choses soient claires et je comprends
que dans une situation inédite de crise
que nous que nous que nous traversons
nous ayons besoin après je voulais dire
au début de mon propos ce que nous
voulons mousse et de la transparence
alors on va continuer dans ce registre
là puisque devant notre commission d'
enquête le cabinet mckinsey indiqué
avoir lieu avoir eu physiquement accès à
la cellule interministérielle de crise
si que au centre de ressources
documentaires ministérielle du ministère
de la santé est-ce que ladite
bibliothèque iclg pas terminée tant il
connaît confirmez vous cette information
et si tel est le cas quelles ont été les
précautions prises pour ouvrir l'accès à
un lieu aussi stratégie
lieux stratégiques c'est la bibliothèque
simone veil je vous y invite volontiers
vous verrez que l'accès est réservé
comme dans une cadre d'une bibliothèque
sauf que là il y avait des lorsqu'il y
avait des documents qui devait rester
elles étaient fermées etc c'est un open
space nous avons créé de l'espace parce
que c'est la guerre nous avons créé de
l'espace là où ils existent et nous
avons aménagé les espaces là où elle
existait une véritable fourmilière vous
y alliez on est dans les moments les
plus durs de la crise le dimanche à 21h
vous étiez sûr de trouver des dizaines
de personnes qui travaillent avec des
tableaux de bord les ordinateurs qu'il
qui était amené évidemment avec chacun
ses missions etc le tout formant j'ai
cette image de fourmilière parce que
vous aviez des espaces sur dédié aux
commandes de matériel d'autres au
transport de matériel autres au stockage
de matériels etc de manière à ce que les
équipes en interaction les unes les
autres puissent servir l'intérêt général
et quelques éléments aussi sur les
marchés publics vous avez évoqué votre
strict respect de ses marchés publics
que nous souhaitons aussi mieux
comprendre un tout simplement
y at il eu d'abord au démarrage donc
c'est des éléments fournis gratuitement
par certaines sociétés cabinet de
conseil ensuite dans le cadre du marché
d'accord cadre de l'année
est-ce que vous avez souscrit
systématiquement au marché du tour en
arabe du tourniquet qui veut que
normalement quant à un cabinet a été
recruté sur une mission ensuite ça soit
un autre cabinet qui lui soit substitué
si vous n'avez si vous y avait dérogé
comme il le semble puisque mckinsey a dû
avoir un plus d'une dizaine de marchés
pour 12 ou 13 millions d'euros comment
se fait-il qu elles ont été les
capacités juridiques de procéder ainsi
première question 0 pro bono aucun
service de conseils gratuits 0 deuxième
question règles du tourniquet respecter
c'est tombé sur mac kinsey au moment de
la campagne vaccinale et vous avez
raison de souligner qu'il ya eu des
continuités deux contre un certes et
prolongation de contrat ou des
renouvellements de contrats qui avaient
trait à la même action et la même
démarche et tire la campagne vaccinale
on peut pas imaginer une seconde que au
bout d'un mois de gestion logistique de
la campagne vaccinale là où nous nous
apercevons que nous avons besoin de
prolonger la démarche de d'appels à une
société de conseil on change
radicalement société de conseil et
convenir de nouvelles personnes donc
c'est cette continuité là qui a fait que
mc kinsey s'est vu attribuer plusieurs
marchés dans la même logique la campagne
vaccinale puisqu'une sur ut pas précisé
combien des marchés
treize de treize 13 13 mais est ce que
la règle du tournoi elle mérite encore
son nom dans ces conditions non mais
monsieur sénateurs ce président si je
vous dis que si je vous disais que de
janvier du 1er janvier au 3 mars je
passe par la société mckinsey pour
organiser enfin pour organiser mais pour
participer à la gestion logistique de la
campagne vaccinale avec les équipes du
ministère avec des centaines de
personnes mobilisées et que le 3 mars
parce que la campagne vaccinale n'est
pas terminée avec elle prend même de
l'ampleur on va passer par l'équipe
d'accenture ou je ne sais quel cabinet
jusqu'au 10 avril dès que le 10 avril en
valais rechercher de nouvelles personnes
ça veut dire que vous passez plus de
temps à accueillir des nouvelles
personnes pour leur expliquer comment ça
marche et que pour recueillir leurs
conseils donc c'est une continuité nous
aurions pu faire un contrat sur une
période d'un an et demi mais là vous
auriez pu me dire mais pourquoi un
contrat d'un an et demi a priori avec
une telle somme là vous ne saviez pas
combien de temps la campagne vaccinale
on était toujours dans le cadre de
renforts intégrés aux équipes sont le
seui se sont toujours c'est toujours le
même contexte de même 4 donc le tournis
qui a été respectée quand il ya eu
d'autres missions que la vaccination et
qu'il fallait faire appel à des cabinets
de conseil de tournai kate a été
appliquée lorsque c'est arrivé autour de
la vaccination de tourniquets s'est
arrêté sur mac kinsey se serait arrêté
sur notre cabinet sur ubc par notre
cabinet aucun aucun sujet là dessus
même le remporte j'essaie toujours de
comprendre monsieur le ministre
donc en décembre 2000 val cabinet
mckinsey toujours lui a mis à
disposition un agent de liaison
pour assurer je cite la coordination
opérationnelle entre santé publique
france et votre ministère sur la
distribution des vaccins et ça et ce
pour un montant
170000 euros donc moi j'ai effectivement
il ya des compétences dans le privé mais
je pense qu'il en a aussi au sein de
notre administration pour assumer ce
genre de mission et cette mission s'est
ensuite prolongé
en janvier 2021 avec la mise en place
d'une tour de contrôle la santé publique
france pour un montant de 600 5000 euros
et mckinsey a notamment participé je
cite encore à la mise en place et à
l'animation
debrief quotidien transverses interne à
santé publique france 2 fois par jour à
9 heures et à 15 heures et donc je
j'aimerais savoir quel a été le rôle
exact de mckinsey à santé publique
france c'est un agent d'interface avec
santé publique france qui a été mis en
place et qui ensuite a été remplacée par
des ressources de quoi interne au
ministère lorsque la situation sanitaire
a permis de le faire
ça rend ça nous a beaucoup beaucoup à
faire ce détail et si vous le souhaitez
ils avaient vu leur mission ils
s'assuraient que les consignes
logistique transmise par la task force
vaccinale était bien appréhender du côté
de santé publique france il veillait à
la fluidité des transmissions et des
relations entre la taskforce vaccinale
et santé publique france et s'assurer
que les alertes de santé publique france
était bien prise en compte dans les
analyses de logistique de la task force
après le départ de mckinsey cette
fonction est exercée par une chargée de
mission au pôle logistique de la task
force en que vous aviez des ressources
internes au ministère
7 sénateurs je me fous karting la
personne qui était planquée dans les
placards on va tous se tourner les
pouces pendant la crise sanitaire si
vous avez un doute encore une fois je
viens vous invitez on a une magnifique
exposition photos de tout ce qui a été
fait par les uns et les autres que ceux
en télétravail ou en présentiel et vous
verrez que chacun était bien employé je
ne crois pas que vous trouverez un
logisticien un ingénieur un cadre où
quelqu'un susceptible de nous aider
pendant la crise sanitaire surtout s'ils
étaient internes au ministère qu'il
n'ait pas été employé à plein pendant
cette période
et quand j'ai vu des possibilités quant
à charge de travail s'est amoindrie
c'est arrivé vous savez entre deux
vagues etc eh bien on a pu à nouveau
utiliser des personnes internes pour
pouvoir remplacer les personnes qui
étaient venues en renfort au moment le
plus dur on parle là de le mot guerre
on parle aussi d'argent public mais on
parle aussi d'argent public parce que si
je n'en attendais si je fais l'addition
170000 euros j'ai un peu 600 5000 euros
ça fait combien
sept cent mille euros sept cent mille
euros pour une personne qui est sûre la
coordination opérationnelle et vous avez
développé ses missions et une personne
pour être dans une tour de contrôle la
santé publique france sincèrement
honnêtement
ne trouvez pas que ça fait un peu cher
la mission
je doute très fort qu'il s'agit de cela
madame la sénatrice qui soirée qui sera
porté pour ça je je vend un bien sûr
vous l'exercez ramé s'est passé de 100
mille euros pour deux personnes et fait
face à messi ni ce qu'on soit d'accord
entre nous est pas ça on peut on peut
rectifier on peut voilà mais ce sont les
éléments qui sont en notre position je
vous avais a soulevé les murs vous faire
une idée juste et c'est pour ça qu'on
vous a transmis ce document où j'ai pas
tout en tête mais c'est pas ça s'est
passé cent mille euros pour une personne
qui fait une liaison ce respect est fait
et la tasse forte certainement pas mais
je vous le redis je sais que vous êtes
de par votre appartenance politique et
votre engagement politique que je salue
sensible à la qualité de vie au travail
je dois vous dire que l'appel dont nous
sommes en train de parler quand vous
dites l'argent public a été bien dépensé
je
sais ce que vous allez me dire vous dis
tout le temps chaque fois que vous êtes
quand vous êtes en séance ici aussi non
c'est pas le sujet je vais peut-être
comme terminer ma phrase mais c'est pas
le sujet jeu malgré tout ma phrase que
vous aviez des lits de camp madame la
sénatrice des lits de camp dans le
ministère des beats corps dans les
bureaux de mes conseillers des beats
quant à côté de la bibliothèque pour que
les gens puissent faire des micro sieste
entre deux missions je vous assure que
les ressources publiques ont reçu le
ministre on a reconnu d'emblée que les
meules et vos personnels ont été
mobilisés à nos questions portent sur
autre chose
et mojo je note que ce que vous avez
déclaré là sur ces deux marchés on va
regarder dans les documents ce qu'il en
est et on en tirera les conclusions que
qui entend devront tirer stéphane scotto
tard elle a donné la parole oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
il me semble et je voulais savoir si
vous pouviez lever cette ambiguïté qui a
peut-être une ambiguïté autour du terme
de conseils parce que le sentiment que
j'ai écouté vos réponses c'est qu'il ya
de nombreuses prestations qui sont des
prestations très opérationnel
d'intervention que on pourrait presque
qualifier d'intérim en quelque part de
renforts d' équipe vous l'avais dit en
mixité des équipes et donc sur des
choses très opérationnelle sur lesquels
on peut s'interroger mais qui sont dans
une contexte particulier et donc ma
question est est-ce qu'il y avait par
ailleurs
et quelle proportion y avait-il
d'intervention au conseil c'est l'iran
en aide à la décision un accompagnement
stratégique qui ne relève pas exactement
de la même nature ni dans son traitement
ni dans son intégration aux équipes
avant tout la liste des actions et des
missions pour nous puissions faire une
opinion mais dans la première partie de
votre intervention est-ce que c'est du
de l'intérim etc je vous le dis on a
besoin de ressources humaines pour
pouvoir compléter des équipes face à la
masse de travail réalisé dans l'urgence
est donc on prend les compétences là où
elles sont je ne le contestait pas dans
ma question 1 simplement c'est une
pratique qui est sans doute très
particulière au contexte tout à même
nous avons élevé parce que je sais que
vous avez souligné et et c'est ce qui
m'intéressait moi dans ma question j'ai
pas là tous les éléments sous les cieux
c'était la proportion du recours au
conseil dit plus stratégiques notamment
pour l'organisation d'une certaine
logistique sûr lesquels il n'y avait pas
forcément de compétences dans vos
équipes pour le faire est-ce que ce ce
conseil stratégique représenter une part
qu elle part elle représentée dans leur
cour ou le mal au conseil est ce que
vous avez une une évaluation de cet
élément-là
du président le vôtre il juge compléter
ou peut-être la question de teva
sautarel
titre d'exemple vous avez
je crois eu recours à la société city
well
pour la distribution des masques
est ce que enfin quand allez vous
utiliser ce que vous avez plus le temps
je me souviens bien d'urgence sans
souliers ensemble est-ce que vous avez
eu le temps par exemple de regarder si
cette société qui intervenait dans la
distribution des masques pourrait avoir
des conflits d'intérêts parce qu'il
apparaît qu'elle avait comme un client
sanofi par exemple
pour cette partie de la question
pardonnez moi c'est absolument pas moi
qui m'occupe de cela dont je ne peux pas
vous répondre encore moins sous serment
il comprend sens de votre question on
essaiera de vous apporter une réponse
bien évidemment sur la question du de
monsieur le sénateur avant oui on a eu
aussi besoin d'avoir des compétences de
nature exceptionnelle sur des renforts
de missions stratégiques
bien sûr et c'est pour ça que je vous ai
parlé de d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai
parlé de public et privé que pour ça que
j'ai parlé de gendarmes pour ce qui est
l acheminement des masques quand il a
fallu transformer des avions
longuement porter en enlevant les sièges
pour voir les envoyer en chine pour les
remplir avec des boîtes de masques jeu
chacun peut imaginer qu au ministère de
co2 des solidarités la santé cette
compétence là n'existe pas donc on est
allé chercher les compétences là où elle
existait c'est à dire en l'occurrence
plutôt du côté militaire puisque on
savait on s'est dit que c'était eux qui
étaient le plus à même de cas et quand
on a eu besoin d'avoir des compétences
stratégiques qui nécessitait des avis
d'experts pointu d'acteurs qui mettait
probablement ce type de les avoir quand
ils travaillent dans le privé nous
l'avons fait aussi
j'ai mon beau père
s'ils n'ont pas
complété la question de mon excellent
collègue sautarel le
c'est à dire que c'est la loi des séries
mais le 26 janvier dernier martin hirsch
avait déjà été interrogé aux questions
d'actualité sur des déclarations de
martin hirsch avec larry devant notre
commission denquête à oui je vous écoute
avoir reçu un appel du cabinet du
premier ministre le 14 mars 2020 et je
me souviens où nous étions à s'étaient
portés dans la pandémie tout début
mars 2000
par tahir je reçois un coup de fil du
cabinet les premiers ministres pour lui
proposer d'intervention pro bono de
plusieurs cabinets de conseil avez vous
été informé vous même par le cabinet du
premier ministre
de ses propositions la réponse est non
ce n'est pas de mon niveau pardonnez moi
c c
est peut-être devient plus générale sur
ses interventions
pro bono de cabinet de conseil
est-ce que vous avez plus j'en veux dire
les encadrer ce que vous avez réussi
tout de suite à m mais il n'y a pas du
tout
aucune
aucune mission pro bono
du ministère au ministère l'avons
maintenu
aujourd'hui
je suis ministre la santé j'ai dit pas
directeur de thq vient d'enregistrer
votre réponse monsieur le ministre
toutefois il semble que le cabinet
mckinsey
akon réaliser une étude pro bono en 2020
pour les services du populiste qui sont
pas les vôtres s'agissait d'une
comparaison des réponses des autres pays
face à la crise sanitaire est ce que
vous avez eu connaissance de cette étude
et quels enseignements en avez-vous tiré
je ne sais pas plus premier ministre et
directeur l'ap-hp est
cependant comme ça concernait le secteur
sanitaire vous auriez pu en avant
c'est une chute de comparaison des
réponses des autres pays face à la crise
sanitaire un benchmark mondial je pense
ou au moins européen j'ai eu des flots
de benchmark j'en ai encore eu
aujourd'hui sous les yeux pour comparer
telle ou telle décision à tel ou tel
moment je ne peux pas vous répondre
actuellement sa venue à reconnaître ou
non très bien mickaël vallet
si monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai deux questions enfin une
question une demande d'appréciation vous
avez précisé tout à l'heure que vous
aviez un contrat en cours renouvelé
récemment avec mckeen's et sur la
question du renfort pour la vaccination
pédiatriques et nous avons eu lorsque
nous avons auditionné mckeen's et
l'information de la part de l'accusé
selon laquelle il avait reçu une
nouvelle commande de l'état à la fin
2021 pour l'organisation de la campagne
de rappel ce que vous pourriez nous nous
nous dira si c'est possible ce soir le
est-ce que vous en êtes avec les
contrats mckeen's et avec l'ensemble des
concerts le temps déchets je vous fais
le paquet global
de la même façon et d'une manière
générale qu'elles sont si c'est possible
de les lister ce soir quelles sont les
prestations
cabinet conseil en lien avec la crise
sanitaire qui sont toujours en cours
qu'est ce que vous avez en cours
aujourd'hui est la deuxième question la
demande d'appréciation
nous recevons des chercheurs et des
universitaires dont plusieurs valide le
terme de consultants cratie hospitalière
s'agissant de l'intervention des
cabinets conseils
nous avons auditionné un certain nombre
de noms va dire de cadres de
responsables dans le domaine public de
la santé notamment la directrice
générale de la rs ile-de-france et la
directrice générale de santé publique
france lorsque nous leur posons la
question de savoir si elle valide ce
qu'elles ressentent
ou comment elle apprécie ce terme-là
avec peut-être un peu de recul sur la
pratique depuis 25 ans je le dis comme
je les ressens tienne on regarde avec
des grands yeux un nom du cabinet
conseil où ça non on sait pas maclean's
et c'est le ministère qui les a pris les
autres c'est pas nous c'est dans les
collectivités hospitalière vous avez une
vision d'ensemble donc même si ça n'est
pas de rapports hiérarchiques toujours
directe la question est est ce que ce
terme de consultants classieux
hospitalière vous le vous le rejetez
totalement est-ce qu'on peut quand même
considérer qu'il ya une intervention
beaucoup plus importante qu'avant et où
se fait-elle principalement y compris
dans les collectivités hospitalière je
dirais deux premiers niveaux
celle dont nous avons l'habitude en tant
qu'élus locaux dans lesquels on siège
parfois dans les conseils
de ceux des ministres de deux
surveillants si
vous parlez d
puisqu'on parlait des collectivités que
vous connaissez mieux que moi je vous
propose avant de parler de consultation
de consultants crassier hospitalière
qu'on regarde la consultent au cra six
dents au sein des collectivités je pense
que si on comparait à budget équivalent
le plat pas ce sera l'objet en
commission mais non mais pardonnez moi
on entre ici dans la maison des élus et
je veux vous m'avez posé une question
d'appréciation je vous propose de
comparer un budget en mettant sur le
même échelle le budget des hôpitaux et
des collectivités et qu'on regarde à
l'échelle des départements par exemple
la participation
dans la gestion des affaires ils sont de
pures supputations n'a aucun chiffre
pour en débat donc on va sur le sujet si
mais je vous propose de creuser c'est
une mission de conseil c'est domicile
non je suis absolument
moi comme je suis quelqu'un qui
m'intéresse beaucoup chose et que je
n'ai pas la réponse j'ai regardé bien
tout ça pour vous dire qu'on est repart
de zéro 26 08 19 % de la part budgétaire
des hôpitaux consacré d'activisme ce
conseil donc je vous laisse juge de
décider si c'est beaucoup ou pas
beaucoup une part qui évolue assez peu
d'ailleurs et qui est et qui à l'échelle
du budget un hôpital représente donc
comme très peu 0,18 0,19 vous êtes sur
le budget global de l'hôpital où vous
êtes sur le fonctionnement ou sur
l'investissement juste le budget de
l'eau le budget lobito vous prenez
budget des hôpitaux vous prenez la part
de budget des hôpitaux consacrer des
missions pour 16 0 18 0 19% selon les
années d'accord maintenant je voudrais
vous avez un chiffre 028 est ce que vous
savez par rapport à la part de
fonctionnement ce que ce qui intéresse
c'est de savoir quand on externalise
entre guillemets ce type de missions de
conseil la question c'est ce qu'on
aurait pu faire en interne est ce que ça
représente en terme de masse salariale
ce qu'en fait c'est là que ça les
universitaires qui nous en parle nous
disent d'abord rien n'est mieux de leur
point de vue il ya souvent un effet
cliquet cyr quand on fait appel à
l'extérieur comme ça du coup on aurait
embauchent plus derrière et on a prouvé
qu'on avait plus besoin je caricature un
peu un point de faire comprendre et
l'autre aspect c'est de se demander si
en interne on n'aurait pas eu ce qu'il
fallait notamment du fait des
regroupements dg acheter etc voilà ce
qu'est ce que c'est que bien que je sois
ministre a été mis en place la nappe
l'agencé nationale d'appui pour les
hôpitaux qui a été chargé de faire de
diligenter des enquêtes à la demande des
hôpitaux parfois la demande d'ailleurs
du ministère des ae grèce et pour venir
en appui des hôpitaux qui ensuite a
diligenté initialement passer des
contrats avec des boîtes de conseils par
exemple et qui ont permis de créer des
guidelines qui ensuite ont mutualisé
gratuitement pour les hôpitaux pour que
ça coûte moins que ça ne coûte plus
c'est à dire ça coûte une fois et ça ne
coûte plus derrière donc voyez que ça
remonte à loin cela n'a pas été créé je
sais plus qui est ministre et crée la
navette puis si c'était marisol touraine
ou ou peut-être roselyne bachelot non
c'était avant c'est bien une brawn même
roselyne qui avait reçu mme bachelot qui
avait qui avait blessé allouache ps et
donc c'est roselyne bachelot a donc
voyait ça a été c'était plutôt c'est
quelque chose qui est plutôt qui va dans
le bon sens
j'ai
coutume de dire que les réformes du
fonctionnement des hôpitaux c'est un peu
comme la mise aux normes incendie de
l'ascenseur donc facile les travaux
savez les normes a déjà changé deux fois
ça ça parle aussi aux collectivités
c'est à dire que les réseaux pitot sont
chargé d'absorber des réformes en flot
continu y'a pas un plfss ans qu'on
touche pas au financement là cette année
c'était financement la psychiatrie etc
et on change le fonctionnement des
tarifications des urgences
pour cette année est donc en réalité les
hôpitaux ils font l'immense majorité du
boulot avec les ressources qu'ils ont en
interne mais par moments quand on parle
par exemple quand les députés et les
sénateurs nous demandent de majorer au
mois de décembre la part de financement
a la qualité pour les hôpitaux pour
l'année à venir ça nécessite un gros
travail de processus qui fait qu'ils ont
parfois sont obligés parfois de faire
appel à des prestataires extérieurs donc
peut-être que c'est une part des
conseils qui sont liées au
fonctionnement des hôpitaux et et j'ai
conscience encore une fois de du travail
que nous leur demandons je vous dis
juste que je ne trouve pas ça j'ai
besoin d'avoir des comparaisons je ne
sais pas pour vous embêter que je
parlais des collectivités c'est que je
pense qu'il n'est pas inintéressant en
étant dans les faits de comparer ce qui
est comparable et je voudrais bien qu'on
puisse comparer des organismes publics
différents un coût de fonctionnement
identique et qu'on regarde qui est la
fin de prestation conseil c'est ainsi
qu'on peut rassurer une idée de ça si on
doit parler consultant cratie
hospitalière ou si on est peut-être dans
une consultant cratie public qui serait
lié au fait qu'on demande tellement de
réformes et de transformation aux
différents organismes publics qui ne
s'en sortent pas tout seul voyez ce que
je veux dire donc je n'encourage pas à
l'appel aux boîtes de conseils pour
mener de tels ou tels projets je suis
ministre en plus en charge de la santé
je suis pas du tout en charge de ces
questions là par contre je si vous me
demandez vous m'avez demandé un avis
personnel sur la question je vous
réponds je pense que le flou continue de
choses à absorber de la part des
hôpitaux fait que par moments ils sont
obligés de faire appel à des
prestataires à des prestations
extérieures et que je suis pas choqué
comme ça de but en blanc mais on va vous
répondre sur le conte fonctionne le coût
de fonctionnement autant je suis très
choqué par le recours à l'intérim en
termes de ressources humaines cette
fois-ci médical ou paramédical qui coûte
une blinde pas possible faire au moins 1
milliard d'euros j'ai fait un rapport
parlementaire pour le des danseurs 2013
c'était 500 millions d'euros à l'époque
c'est sans doute un milliard voix pu
voir plus maintenant c'est à dire à peu
près 10 fois l'équivalent de toutes les
dépenses de conseils hospitalière annuel
ça me choque plus
je veux vous ramener sur la première
partie de la question de notre collègue
valais c'est cette nouvelle commande
mckinsey pour la campagne de rappel est
ce que vous pouvez nous préciser le
contenu de cette commande le montant et
puis nous plaidé que ces deux commandes
et chapeau aussi aux tourniquets étant
une commande de d'une campagne d'une
campagne de vaccination de rappel
est ce qu'elle ne pouvait pas être
envisagée dans un autre cas
d'autant moins monsieur le sénateur mon
sens
notamment dès qu'on parle de rappel et
la continuité de la pop et de la
poursuite de la campagne de rappel et la
poursuite de la campagne fight night 4 x
et deux en un pour répondre à votre
question il ya également une mission qui
est en cours sur les prestations sur le
numérique qui n'est pas terminée et
après c'est dans les documents qu'on
vous a transmis dire s'il y en avait
d'autres
mais c'est sûr du numérique c'est à dire
qu'on a eu on adapte tous sentis coni
dans la nappe le pass interface
vaccinale on est en permanence donc
voilà donc lancé une mission qui a
initié avec décodeur thaddée
est ce qu'on va trouver dans vos
documents le montant de cette nouvelle
commande vous avez tous les montants de
toucher commandes passées parce qu'il va
y avoir imagine plusieurs bons de
commande à l'intérieur de cette
prestation je pense qu'il ya un marché
initial avec un total s'est toujours dit
c'est le même marché
nico lui rends ton amour à part merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
hier nous avons auditionné florence
parly ministre des armées donc le
ministre des armées dispose de sa propre
structure de conseil depuis 2020 donc de
nombreuses opérations sont menées par
les fonctionnaires de votre ministère
mais envisagez vous de développer
davantage votre propre structure afin de
réduire votre recours aux cabinets
privés je vous remercie
si vous passez vous l'avez dit c'est pas
un appel à le faire mais si vous
additionnez la directrice générale de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales elle pourrait vous sortir le
nombre de lettres de mission et de
saisine de l'igas que j'ai signé
moi-même près et demander des renforts
donc évidemment d'où nous nous
travaillons à cela et puis nous
enrichissons aux nouvelles
il est fier d'inviter positif de cette
crise terrible c'est que j'ai pu obtenir
des moyens supplémentaires pour
l'ensemble des administrations en
territoire je donne un exemple tenait le
ségur l'investissement en santé 19
milliard d'euros 2,2 d'investissement
c'est colossal reprise de dettes 3000
hôpitaux ehpad vous le savez rénover
moderniser et c'est pour arriver à faire
que ça ça déroule vite et qu'on ne perd
pas de temps parce que les élus les
citoyens nous demande d'avoir cet
hôpital neuf de rénover cette unité
hospitalière il va falloir évidemment
suivre cela de très près dans les
territoires et donc j'ai demandé et
obtenu des équivalents temps plein qui
sont temporairement délégué aux agences
régionales de santé pour pouvoir de
veiller au bon fonctionnement de la mise
en place opérationnelle du ségur
d'investissement donc je n'ai pas pu me
passer par une société de prêt privé mon
premier réflexe a été de me dire
renforce les airs et ce pendant quelques
années avec des gens qui savent faire ça
et qui soit dédié spécifiquement à ça
donc on augmente la masse salariale
c'est ce que nous faisons quand nous
mettons en place le le
versement automatisé pour les pensions
alimentaires intermédié nous savons
qu'il faut renforcer les effets qui les
effectifs des caf parce que ça va faire
des missions nouvelles il ya des
missions qui porte sur le système
d'information et d'autres sur l'accueil
et le traitement des dossiers donc nous
renforçons les administrations après on
nous reproche de ne pas avoir supprimé 7
postes de fonctionnaires mais c'est à
cela que ces fonctionnaires serbes dans
la vraie vie
mais blanc oui merci à monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre est
évidemment on espère tous ne plus jamais
traversé une crise sanitaire comme celle
que nous avons traversée nous traversons
encore une fois j'ai été très attentive
à vos propos et j'ai bien compris
l'urgence qu'il y avait à y compris
faire appel à du privé pour accompagner
les agents de la fonction publique dans
l'eure dans leur mission
je voudrais bien malheureusement nous
avons une expérience
imaginons parce que nous n'espérons pas
que nous subissions encore une crise
d'une telle ampleur quelle expérience
tirez vous de celle qui est en cours
est-ce que vous pensez que vous
prendriez si vous êtes toujours en phase
finale finalement que vous prendriez les
mêmes mesures ou est ce que vous ne
pensez aux s que vous pouvez imaginer
que au sein de la fonction publique
on pourrait
créer les conditions pour que
lily en nombre et en qualité j'oserais
dire des fonctionnaires capable
d'assumer les missions qui vous ont fait
qu'il était qui ont été assumés par le
privé ces derniers temps
ce que vous pensez que c'est possible
même à porter on va tomber d'accord sur
un point j'en suis à peu près sûr c'est
que vous et moi on conteste le procès en
excès d'agents publics dans les agences
régionales de santé
un procès que j'entends en permanence
on me dit les agrès sont pléthoriques
bamert porter on a demandé aux agences
régionales de santé en plus de leur
mission qu'elle ne pouvait pas
abandonner prévention détection des
cancers vérification de la qualité de
l'eau de l'air gestion pilotage des
hôpitaux des regarder en ce moment on
est en train de dire est ce que les ars
ont fait c'est de contrôler les ehpad en
plein milieu de la crise sanitaire il
fallait évidemment maintenir des
missions normales et en plus absorber
des missions nouvelles extraordinaires
1600 centres de vaccination les
logistiques monstrueuse en matière de
ces déserts est ce qu'ils font en irak
les préfets mais ce sont les airs est ce
qu'il faut ce sont les équipes des ars
si les ars avait été capable sans
renfort de maintenir leur fonction leur
fonctionnement normal pour leur mission
du quotidien et en plus mais j'ai genre
et en plus de gérer d'absorber ces
surplus de missions liées à la crise
vous pourriez me dire ça veut dire que
quand y'a pas de crise peut-être
qu'elles sont pléthoriques la réponse
est non et par définition une crise
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas pu
éviter donc quand une crise survient par
définition elle ne déborde et donc quand
une crise survient vous fait face et
vous utiliser tous les moyens
disponibles pour répondre très
clairement à votre question intéresse ce
sont pas pléthoriques de nous les
renforçons le volley départemental en
ligne que les élus locaux notamment
parce qu'on a vu que c'était très
important de faire
trois s'ils avaient une nouvelle crise
qui devait arriver locales ou nationales
épidémique environnementales ou que
sais-je et que si nous avions dans
l'urgence besoin de prendre des
décisions et de faire appel à des
compétences ou qu'elle soit je ne me
cacherai pas je ferai appel à des
compétences où qu'elles se trouvent
qu'elles soient publiques ou qu'elles
soient privées pour ça que je reprends
pour peut-être pour terminer
l'introduction que vous m'avez prêté et
qui est que je revendique j'ai eu des
compétences partout avec des gens de
bonne volonté qui pouvait nous aider
nous apporter
on protège et français dans cette
période au nom de quoi nous en serions
nous priver donc de la même manière on
parle d'une hypothèse d'une nouvelle
crise quelle qu'elle soit je crois que
celles et ceux qui me succéderont quel
que soit leur bord politique à ce moment
là prendront des décisions qui viseront
avant tout à protéger les français et on
ne renforcera pas mais nous les
remboursons je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure au regard des deux vous est
donné l'exemple de drs qui sont
renforcées dans le volley départemental
des équivalents temps plein
supplémentaires qui ont été créés et
puis il faudra tirer une réflexion
peut-être un peu plus générale qu'on
appelle le réflexe de la crise le retour
d'expérience de cette crise et les
nouvelles compétences qui ont qui se
sont fait jour et qui ont été créés des
gens convaincus de nouvelles compétences
dans les territoires les agences faut
les conserver parce qu'un jour on aura
peut-être besoin de faire appel à ne pas
les perdre c'est précieux
c'est précieux ensuite des besoins qui
se font jour en matière de
réorganisation de structure bonjour on a
débattu est ce que l'eprus la
disparition de l'eprus la fusion toutes
ces structures dans santé publique
france que c'était une bonne idée est-ce
que l'empilement des structures spf dgs
has et c est une bonne idée ou non
permettez moi de dire j'ai une opinion
et j'aurais évidemment des propositions
à formuler en matière de réorganisation
du paysage sanitaire et de la manière de
nous préparer à répondre et de prévenir
l'émergence de nouvelles crises futures
on ne le fait pas pendant la crise on ne
fait pas ça pendant la crise donc voila
mais ont chacun aura j'imagine que dans
les programmes des différents candidats
je n'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu mention dans
le programme de madame des classes que
j'ai rien on n'était pas vous aussi la
halle à la criée électorale dans cette
commission s'il veut
du temps du candidat donc que si non non
non non
d'avoir une idée sur laquelle je sais ce
que je voulais vous dire on en restera
là si vous voulez bien et on évitera ce
genre d'incident patrice joly avait
demandé la porte si monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
reviens sur la question et des contrats
sur leur nature et sur la typologie ces
contrats là d'ordinaire on fait appel à
des cabinets pour des prestations de
services pour définir des projets sur
des missions qui sont définies et c est
là où vous avez quand même plutôt évoqué
l'idée de mise à disposition de
personnel et donc nous aurons sûrement
les éléments dans les documents vous
avez les éléments de réponse dans les
documents vous avez fourni mais mais
juridiquement et au regard de ddd de ce
qui a été confié à ses personnels là je
m'interroge sur ce qui pourrait être des
sept évoquée par le collègue les
questions sur les formes d'intérim ou
sur la notion de prestations services
qui est généralement ou de conseil qui
est confié à ses agents sans qu'elle
vous avez eu recours
je vais prolonger un tout petit peu le
l'interprétation de patrice joly sur la
question déontologique aussi parce que
on n'a pas parlé tout à l'heure mais
quand vous avez décrit l'incorporation
de ces personnels aux équipes pensaient
que nos agents publics son rôle de face
ou mis à une déontologie bien précise et
c'est important parce que là ils ont des
données sanitaires
importantes à traiter mais on a quand on
passe un contrat de prestations en effet
comme ça vient d'être décrit avec un
cabinet de conseil à tout un ensemble de
précautions déontologiques qui sont
prises après ça pose la question du
contrôle c'est une autre question là
quels étaient les précautions prises ou
est ce que dans l'urgence mais pas pu
les prendre
et contrat prévoit des clauses de
confidentialité vous le savez
et la loi ne prévoit pas d'aller
vérifier le les activités antérieures où
les miens familiaux des uns et des
autres dans le cadre des activités donc
je nous avons vraiment pour le coup
scrupuleusement respecté la loi que la
lettre de la loi
si vous
bougez malgré votre question où je vous
réponds on est resté parfaitement dans
le cadre de la loi sur toutes ces
questions là non mais comme on n'a pas
vu c'est le type de contrat cloud passé
avec ces renforts entre guillemets on a
du mal à comprendre comment ça se passe
parce que encore une fois on le comprend
dans le cadre du recours à un cabinet de
conseil pour une mission bien identifié
un cahier des charges il ya des
obligations en matière de sécurité y
compris de sécurité informatique de
confidentialité et c'est bon je pense
qu'aussi le donneur d'ordres vérifie qui
a pas de conflit d'intérêts comme le
déclare le soumissionnaire le cabinet de
conseil parce que il peut aussi
travailler pour un laboratoire pour des
grandes entreprises privées qui peuvent
avoir des intérêts divergents tout s'est
vérifié dans le cadre on nous a bien
expliqué dans le cadre de du contrat qui
est passé avec le cabinet de conseil
très bien ça pose quand même la question
du contrôle je n'y reviens pas
mais quand vous nous expliquez vous avez
besoin de renfort est qu en effet comme
ça vient d'être décrit par nos deux
collègues comme vous l'avez expliqué ans
au début il s'agit de personnel mis à
disposition d'une certaine façon je vous
pose la question du type de contrat qui
garantit lequel les conditions
déontologique de leur intervention le
contrat garantit les règles de
confidentialité tels que prévoient les
règles il ya aucun
lien extradé mais les règles de
confidentialité sont garantis par le
contrat au même titre que n'importe qui
et donc
à part la confidentialité les intérêts
les éventuels conflits d'intérêts
comment sont ils pris en compte la loi
ne prévoit pas d'aller regarder les
éventuels liens ou confit d'intérêt est
une personne que vous prenez dans le
cadre d'une mission externe ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure nous
respectons la loi peut pas aller au delà
de la loi est la loi aujourd'hui ne
prévoit pas de faire cela
on pourrait avoir des intervenants
externes qui par ailleurs on travaille
et dans le cadre de leurs fonctions de
salariés chez cabinet de conseil pour
des entreprises qui pouvaient avoir qui
pourraient avoir des intérêts divergents
c'est les règles du marché des hits
effet je suis fait apprécier sa part ce
parce qu'arsenal battu jeune afrique qui
se passe technique dans tmc présence
n'est pas mon temps mon niveau de
décision mais je vous dis on vous dit
elle que les choses sont faites dans le
ministère que dont j'assume la
responsabilité jour on dit cela il pense
pas très joli target pour boursiers sans
gloire et sur le cadre juridique il me
semble que les contrats de prestation de
services aux geeks au régime de la
commande publique je ne suis pas sûr que
ce qui relève des contrats d'intérim
relève de ce même régime et donc pense
qu'il ya une histoire de qualification
mais sûrement que les documents vous
avez fourni nous permettrons
effectivement d'aller de faire cette
analyse
jérôme bosch ne se fasse pas une
prestation d'intérim majorité ce n'est
pas de l'intérêt c'est une prestation de
ressources humaines ce conseil mais ce
n'est pas deux intérims donc ça ne
répond pas aux contrats de l'intérim est
vraiment d'appréciation de conseils
importants tels que vous ne l'aviez
définit enfin présenté le renforcement
laisser penser que c'était centres
d'intérêts c'est du renforcement en
conseil n'est pas la forme pas du
renforcement en intérim
j'aimerais votre sentiment et donc c'est
un sentiment avant comme la vérité la
vérité sur tout ça
est ce qu'on ne devrait pas lorsqu'on
fait appel comme cela mr pur jantes à
des agents privés qu'ils soient
considérés selon les mêmes règles de
déontologie que les agents temporaires
du service public
la veille tp leur ville envisage de le
faire de sa relève de la loi et nous y
serions moi je voudrais à gagner sur
personnel je suis très favorable j'ai
aucun problème et c'est au contraire
tout ce qui nous permettra d'éviter
de nous trouver dans des situations qui
pourraient être problématiques a
posteriori je serai totalement d'avis et
je ma courte carrière de parlementaire
la lutte contre les biens et les
conflits d'intérêts n'a pas été en reste
dans les engagements que j'ai pu j'ai pu
avoir donc le mais encore une fois je
n'ai pas comme ministre je ne vais pas
demander à mes services de d'excéder ce
qui dans la loi parce que ça pourrait
aussi bien m'être reprochée langue si on
modifie la loi ou si la déité pas
modifié ses règles je le suivrai avec
satisfaction
est encore une question sous ministre au
delà de la crise sanitaire le site
internet du ministère de la santé
indique et je cite là que la stratégie
nationale de santé constitue le cadre de
la politique de santé en france donc
j'ai une question d lopp pourquoi
confier son évaluation à un cabinet de
conseil mckinsey en particulier qui a
reçu trois commandes en janvier juillet
et octobre 2021 pour un montant global
de 1,12 million d'euros est ce que vous
pourriez nous préciser l'apport de ce
travail et les conséquences bien
évidemment qui ont été marqués en ont
été tirés
je pense même les rapports taxé d'une
aide ponctuelle dans une période qui est
compliquée je ne connais pas du tout le
détail de ses prestations
et une aide ponctuelle pour un million
cent mille euros quand
je peux bien m'imaginer qu'on ait besoin
d'être dans la période avec toutes les
transformations et les réformes savez
monter 700 lits de réanimation de façon
durable recruter similé formé six mille
infirmières aides-soignants de plus
travailler
at&t cloisonné rogombé lutter contre les
déserts médicaux faire l'émission ne
manque pas d'enjeux comme je ne sais pas
de quoi il en retourne les cédants et
documents qu'on vous a envoyé vous
pourrez vous faire une idée de la nature
la mission mais je ne suis pas étonné du
fait qu'on ait besoin de mission d'appui
dans la période aussi vous rêvez 2021
informations qu'on a trouvées sur le
site internet du ministère mais si c'est
une mission de conseil avec une mission
tout de conseils diligentée par
ministère vous avez le détail ainsi que
les toutes les formalités au sein des
pièces que nous vous avons envoyé
[Musique]